what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder and i know
during my live stream on thursday for
those of you who were there i mentioned
that i was going to be very cautious
about doing
venom 2 let there be carnage trailer
update videos
i know a lot of people want to know when
exactly we're going to get this trailer
it's super long
overdue and although we called that
little title revealed 10 second little
clip a teaser it's not really a teaser
and having said that today we actually
do have some venom
ii let there be carnage leaks and these
are leaks that actually point towards
the trailer coming pretty soon
so we'll go over these leaks one of them
is rather interesting because it hints
towards
venom actually existing in the same
universe as
tom holland spider-man something that
we've been hoping for
for a while and hopefully that becomes
reality before we get started quick
reminder about my stormbreaker giveaway
all you gotta do is subscribe to my
channel subscribe to cosmic culture and
the detail giveaways are in the
description down below
so the first thing we'll talk about
actually isn't a leak it's something
that's just out there in plain sight
but it is something that does lead us to
believe that the venom
let there be carnage trailer is going to
be coming pretty soon
and that is the fact that you can now
buy venom
let there be carnage merch and this is
very
official merch if you go to
shopdisney.com you can actually buy a
venom
leatherby carnage t-shirt and this is a
big deal and if you're asking why it's a
big deal it's because
promotion for the movie is officially
starting and you don't start promoting
for a movie unless people
actually really know what the movie is
about otherwise everybody would simply
be like
what is this for so they are now selling
these t-shirts at shopdisney.com
hot topic box lunch and a few other
places as well which is really good
news because that means the trailer
should be right around the corner
now some insiders like daniel rpk have
said that the trailer is coming soon
they presumed that it was going to be in
april but obviously that didn't happen
but they are sticking to their guns and
saying that it is coming soon and the
sell of this merchandise is a good sign
and another good sign is actually a leak
that we got a little bit ago
what was once a lego leak is now
officially on sale
and they are of venom and carnage again
a good sign that carnage and venom
material are on sale because that means
promotion for the film is going to start
very soon in fact it's kind of already
started at this point but there is
something very
interesting to look at on this box on
these boxes
it says assembled from the spider-man
universe
now there's a lot to unpack here because
of the new deal with disney and sony so
regardless
of this lego set there is a lot to talk
about but let's talk about this
because it could mean something but it
also could mean nothing now
sony does have the rights to spider-man
on film
for those of you who never heard the
full story marvel sold the rights of
spider-man to sony in 1998. this
included everything from merchandising
and film
but it did not include comics but in
2011
sony sold the merchandising rights to
spider-man back to marvel
and therefore disney since disney owns
marvel so that means right now as we
speak
disney owns the merchandising rights to
spider-man so the fact that this lego
set says assembled from the spider-man
universe
could and unfortunately probably does
mean nothing
however that doesn't mean that
spider-man and venom won't cross
paths in fact they probably will and i
know a lot of people are saying that
this won't happen until after
venom let there be carnage however that
isn't necessarily true and we kind of
actually already have some proof that
the two universes the
sp umc or the sony pictures universe of
marvel characters a name of which i
really really don't like but
that universe and the mcu could actually
cross over a little bit
and i'll explain how that could happen
and i'll talk about the evidence that we
have so far
and talk about how it could actually be
the plan of sony
and disney to have tom holland
spider-man and tom hardy's
venom interact with each other so the
first thing that you need to know is the
fact that
sony actually does want the crossover in
fact
they kind of wanted it to happen in the
first venom film and i say kind of
because it wasn't going to be a battle
with spider-man but they wanted tom
holland's peter parker to be in the film
it was revealed that sony wanted tom
holland's peter parker to visit the live
foundation
on a field trip with his class in the
first venom movie
now we saw venom and that obviously
didn't happen and the reason that didn't
happen
is because of marvel disney sony pushed
for this to happen but marvel and disney
said no because they didn't want people
to confuse the two universes
essentially the mcu didn't want people
to think that venom was a part of the
mcu
which sucks because that's what we all
want however that doesn't mean that we
won't see the two of them interact
sony clearly wants tom holland
spider-man in their spumc
and it looks like they may have come to
a deal with marvel and disney on how to
make this happen
we're all aware of that pretty big scare
that happened about a year and a half
ago where we weren't really sure
if spider-man was going to be in the mcu
anymore sony and disney were kind of in
a disagreement about how much profit
disney was going to get from the
spider-man
mcu films now fortunately they worked it
out spider-man remains in the mcu
however they did
do a new deal and this deal was kept
very secret
however a few insiders in the past did
say that the new deal did
include some things that sony wanted one
of them was the ability for tom holland
spider-man to cross
into their spumc the new deal was
rumored to be that
tom holland could cross over into the sp
umc and some of the characters from the
spumc
including venom could cross over into
the mcu
as long as it was in a spider-man film
meaning you could only see these
characters in a spider-man film
not in an iron man film or captain
america film or guardians of the galaxy
only a spider-man film and then we got a
little bit of
evidence towards this and it came in the
form of the morbius trailer
in the morbius trailer there are two
things that stand out
one is that michael keaton's vulture
made an appearance
now of course he is from the mcu he was
introduced in spider-man homecoming but
it appears like he has crossed over to
the
spumc adding some truth to this rumored
new deal where the characters could jump
over into different universes
as long as they remained in a spider-man
film however in the sp
umc they can do whatever they want and
they can use them in any movie they want
more proof came when we saw a picture of
spider-man
on the wall the words murderer painted
over him
this implies that one not only does
spider-man exist
in the sp umc but it appears to be the
same spider-man even though he's not
wearing the same
tom holland suit he's actually wearing
the sam raimi suit but the word murderer
over him
implies that this is tom holland
spider-man and people think that he
killed
mysterio because of the end of
spider-man far from home where mysterio
framed him
this combined with a leaked photo that
we actually got from the morbia set
showing the dailybugle.net which also
appears at the very end of spider-man
far from home in the post credits where
we saw jjj
confirms that there are indeed some
crossovers between the universes
happening
this is a very good sign and another
good sign is the fact that
marvel disney and sony actually just
recently worked out another new deal
this deal is for the spider-man films to
be on disney plus
this is an extremely good sign because
this means that sony and disney slash
marvel are playing very well with each
other right now
and why wouldn't they hopefully
spider-man no way home is going to be a
spider-verse film adding other
sony spider-man like toby maguire and
andrew garfield into the mcu
all of this is a really good sign that
eventually we will see spider-man
and venom cross paths with each other
now will that happen in venom
let there be carnage probably not at
least not in the way that people would
like to see
yes tom holland could make a cameo in
venom let there be carnage but i don't
think that spider-man is going to be
doing much fighting i think they're
going to keep the focus on venom and
carnage
and then in the next film have
spider-man and venom
face off against each other and this
would honestly be better that way they
wouldn't have
to share the screen time with venom
carnage and spider-man it could just be
venom vs spider-man so the future of
venom
and spider-man is very very bright and
hopefully we are going to get this venom
let there be carnage teaser trailer very
very
soon in the meantime don't forget to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all of the latest
venom leatherby carnage and spiderman
news don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof